il ya une chagnaud propose en compagnie
de pierre bruneau voyage sans passeport
faux
obama
y renoncer parce que vous avez connu
l'afrique du nord que vous avez poussé
plus loin votre investigation et cela
vous a conduit ici au caire n'est ce pas
oui exactement
au caire la plus grande ville d'afrique
qu'est ce que nous voyons nous sommes
ici sur la place de constitution le
quartier moderne du caire extrêmement
moderne et assez peu grouillant tout à
fait oui cette vente la chaleur ici vous
voyez la vallée du nil d'un douzième
étage est ici sont une plongée dans la
rue lily mila qui conduit aux minarets
non qui conduit url oui justement elle
est très long elle est assez l'ordre
elle est beaucoup plus oui en août elles
sont des maisons détruites sont de
vieilles maisons
vous avez une vue sur les minarets du
caire qui sont voulons de 400 ils sont
très variées no spam
celui ci a vu plus la flèche signifie
envol parfait mais il s'est curieusement
ce sig aucune porte
il est pas facile d'essayer de s'en
approcher je crois de minerais
citrouille mobile accéder facilement
aussi la plus ancienne mosquée du caire
parce que toulouse la mosquée nasser pas
une citadelle parfaitement pas fermée
le mihrab à gauche en direction de la
mecque et le mans bas à droite
c'est très riche comme oui c'est une
riche mosaïque aux aidants les bleu et
marron dans l'ue argent or marin rouge
qu'est ce que l'on voit seulement bois
désistement je lui demandais ce que vous
voyez sur les plafonds aussi la grande
mosquée s'alimente achats construite au
siècle dernier
enfin
caisse et oiseaux c'est un route sans
traitement vaucaire s'alimente achats
s'est rendu coupable d'une grand
massacre de l'histoire celui des
mamelouks sa garde prétorienne
en une journée il dans ce massacre et
rami bien les craignait beaucoup il est
traqué en vain
la cour de la mosquée dans ma roue
aussi les deux grandes mosquées du caire
et peut-être les plus grandes du monde
arabe sont l'une en façade et lifan
l'une en face de l'autre
l'une à côté d'un côté des elles sont un
groupe architectural très importante qui
a servi de forteresse devant la
citadelle
y à l'intérieur de la plus grande
mosquée nous aidera
g ce sont les minarets de la mosquée al
azhar la porte des barbiers par lesquels
le touriste naître un dossier qu'est-ce
qui était sur le mur un cadran solaire
la mosquée al azhar est une université
où on apprend surtout la théologie et de
droit musulman dans la ville la tordue
il est confondant les criminels
autrefois et/ou selim et d'exécuter
faute d'adversaire to buy
pour l'instant c'est le marché pas sur
la fin les deux minarets qui voyait la
mosquée voisine estime bryan dourcy
d'accord un camel est immense et
magnifique à sept mètres de hauteur
elle est en bois rond voiture
un très joli comme couleur
cette masse qu'elle est la seule à
posséder un jardin dans sa cour
intérieure du groupe de goyave 6 points
ce sont des foules du fleur mordant le
flamboyant voici les deux minarets
il se trouvait sur la porte close les
plus tôt
de l'intérieur de la mosquée dans la rue
qu'est ce qu'il transporte le printemps
des pastèques ici des marolles c'est
vraiment bon bastin que c'est délicieux
surtout très rafraîchissant alors oui ça
doit pas avoir le même goût de ce que
l'on trouve ici
non du tout c'est un type dégustateurs
de passer l'air d'apprécier
et elle est nue admirable les
informations nous les enfants sont en
cause
tractions blanc ils ont beaucoup de
droits à la longue durée
est ce que c'est parce qu'ils sont
obligés de partis défendant très chevelu
parce que très jeunes ils sont attendus
eux mêmes voyez le plafond encore
intacte une mosquée voisine
et c'est en quoi sous plafond soetens
tuque alors double aussi un arc byzantin
dans une grimace est abandonnée voici
deux trains jeudi vitro vous savez que
l'armé blanche le père ne le permet pas
la représentation des figures humaines
était sage la métrique s'est beaucoup
développée grâce ici sur les sur les
façades des minarets
sur les ports
nous souhaitons trois fois ça se
construit une magnifique tombeau dans la
nécropole aussi venue de 81 email qui
est un chemin de la ram du xvème siècle
on peut pénétrer à l'intérieur a
facilement se masse qui d'ailleurs ne
sont pas très occupée par les fidèles
est ce qu'on est obligé de retirer ses
souliers pas bowling où vous tirez vos
chaussures vous jouez des grandes
grandes pantoufles et il faut dire que
c'est très reposant
lorsqu'on a la fille longtemps dans la
ville où juin cet artisan est en train
d'incruster un plein de mois de 10 voire
de nac 1,2 et des bennes ce travail
artisanal suppositions un très joli
travail c'est le plus beau souvenir
confus sera porté à mon avis est c'est
très curieux
oui un lien qui joue du violon non du
tout c'est un tour à archet il est en
train de tourner des perles en matière
plastique couleur dambre faut faire des
chapelets musulmans maronite mar au
niveau 6 mai où chantait cp1 et yonnel
voici un graveur censée perdre excusez
nous pour suivre mais où sont ses pairs'
été c'était la même chose que les
interviews débats ce n'est son dynamique
du bâtonnet en général celui ci comme
celui des incrustations plat tout à
l'heure
ne fais pas de dessin et originaux fur
et à mesure oui tout ça va très vite
mais on retrouve sur les tapis et
dessins géométriques que vont trouver
d'accord
les autres voici un barman dans l'union
qui vous offrent à leur demande une
langue du petit marchande date est ce
que l'on raconte un peu classique
mentionné nos héros en voici d'autres
routes elles sont une ressource
déserteurs ont l'argent beaucoup plus
désertiques le 6 mai
aux abords du massif montagneux
la piste
c'est assez difficile quelques faits
n'existent pas du tout il faut la
chercher dans libé wen
cette triangulaire 7 calculée au ses
traits rouges par endroits par beaucoup
d'endroits noire des opposants dans
celui des cantonales en plus la
lumineuse non mais oui aussi le registre
de l oued ifrane un reposant
ici le jardin de l'ancien député
épiscopat qui existait avant le coup
vente sainte-catherine est ce personnage
c'est un super droit qui peuplent la
région vivent surtout du trafic due à 6
ah ben oui on a trouvé du pétrole et qui
change un peu les conditions de vie mais
le chiffre est cependant heureux c'est
pas ficher elle pense de suite à
l'entrevue bien connu
du jardin du couvent cimail le couvent
de sainte catherine dans le jardin ou
peut-être distinguer un petit édifice
blanc c'est le smer
dans lequel on peut pénétrer dans si on
veut connaître et nous verrons tout à
l'heure ou pouvant être une forteresse
autrefois et on y fait l'attrait que par
un monte charge ne va pas car les moines
ont dû subir les attaques et les assauts
des bédouins pillards du désert sont des
petits enfants des lions depuis
l'entente de loin qui lui sera pas aux
dépens des moines à l'intérieur du
monastère c'est la première réelle qui
vous apercevez monastère est comme une
petite ville il se montre ses remparts
nous sommes là et ses immenses et kotaku
nous voyez une mosquée et les lives le
père supérieur ford
ici le cimetière où sont enterrés
provisoirement moines avant que le
reboisement de choix compilées dans le
maire michel ressemble un peu à nous qu
état quand vous est il exactement ce que
l'on voit ce qu'on va vanter comme la
cloche qui appelle à la prière
trois ou quatre appartements de simandre
qui est l'ancien gone d'appel à la
prière
bewkes de bois accélérer les cellules
sont dispersés un peu partout au gré de
l'imagination des moines qui le
construit ça et là
les uns sont installés dans l'épaisseur
du rempart
sont à l'abri d'un chaland certainement
un site à des vieux livres setteuse
défense et l'aimerait non non ce sont
deux de vieille bible en grec qui les
moines sont des grecs orthodoxes et et
voici un édit de napoléon par lequel il
ordonne que soit ristori les remparts
monastère le père nick frost et
accueille les visiteurs
vous présente une image de sainte
catherine et bien merci infiniment
pierre bruneau pour ce premier voyage
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de pierre bruneau de
solange péters montage pierre michel rey
sont paul bonnefond illustration sonore
d'aunis blazer